It's hard. It's hard to believe.
It's hard to believe what I said like this across you, but, but,
but Henry Kissinger, the national security advisor,
uh, uh, he, he called you the most dangerous man in America.
Do you, do you know if he's still of that opinion?
Quite possibly. Uh,
he knew that I was dangerous to his Nixon's Vietnam policy
because he knew that I knew the truth of what that policy was,
which they were lying to the public about.
He knew that I knew they weren't threatening nuclear weapons at that time
against North Vietnam was very important that I not reveal that.
Um, I want to talk to you about top security clearance,
and I know there are several levels of top security clearance.
How does that change a person?
Well, as I said to Kissinger,
when I was working for him at the beginning of the administration,
I want to give you some advice if I can, on the effect this has, uh,
at first I said at first,
the first reaction will be amazement that all this information existed and
you'll feel like a fool that, uh, you didn't know about it before,
even though you knew top secret material,
but after a little while you get used to it and you feel that everyone else who
doesn't have the clearances is a fool.
And you'll find that you'll be speaking to people and saying,
what would they be telling me if they knew what I knew, which by the way,
what he knew might be true or false, it was just highly secret.
It didn't have to be true. What would they do? Well, that's too complicated.
So you'll stop listening and all you'll be doing is you won't run from anyone.
You'll just think of what you want to tell them what you want them to believe.
You'll become something like a sear sees captives
in, uh, the Odyssey who, uh,
had a potion that turned men into swine.
They couldn't communicate like men anymore at the time. Uh,
yes, I was telling him what I'd gone through. And I think everyone had,
who'd had these clearances. And I must say that, uh,
a year later when I was advising him to read the Pentagon papers in San
Clemente, and I was describing his Cambodia invasion,
which led to the resignations of these other people as, uh,
not looking that different from, uh, uh, other people.
And he'd been advised to that extent by some of his colleagues from Harvard
earlier, Tom shelling and some others. And he said,
but they didn't have the clearances. So he couldn't take them seriously.
And I saw that he had imbibed CRCs potion, uh,
and was out of communication. He wasn't able to learn.
You were, you were a man of war in a way. You were a part of the,
the, the, the war effort and, and a very important part as well.
W looking back, what, what is the,
the success you've had you had back then that you today regret the most?
I couldn't say I had any success. Uh,
you might've the state's policy as a whole.
I can't think of anyone who would look back and say that our policy succeeded in
any way or that they'd had any useful.
No, but what do you regret the most that you, you tried and you managed,
and then you regretted it?
Oh, by far I regret that I did not reveal
early in 1961, before I worked on Vietnam,
the nuclear documents that were then in my possession and which were insane and
murder is to a degree that humans had never imagined in
human history.
And I've regretted ever since that's over half a century that I didn't reveal
those at the time when I had them.
Talk about that, uh, in a short while. But I, I.
Itself, I put out the Pentagon papers to the Senate in 1969.
They did not hold hearings. I gave them to the press in 1971.
This was the history of our horrible decision-making in Vietnam. Uh,
from 1945 to 68, became known as the Pentagon papers.
I regret that I had not put all those documents out in 64 before the war had
really begun, uh, in a big way when it might really have prevented the war. Uh,
that's a heavy weight on my shoulders that I didn't do that.
But do you, you weren't, I mean, after all, you were a Marine and you came from,
from, from the, the military side and, and, uh,
I don't know if you, how to, what degree you were in combat or.
I was in the Marines, uh, during peace time, uh,
essentially except for the Suez crisis,
which where I was going to Alexandria Harbor, but, um, uh,
that was in peace time from 54 to 57.
And then later I was in Vietnam from 65 to 67 and there I was a
civilian for the state department.
I switched from the defense department at the highest level to the state
department.
Being a part of the, the American war effort. Um,
dating a peace activists as you did, because your wife,
I became, yeah. Uh, did this changed you? I mean, how,
how did that work?
The greatest influence on me was, um,
meeting young man in those days,
it was old man graft resistors who had been influenced by Gandhi and by Martin
Luther King and Rosa parks, and were living that life.
And they were using their own lives to make the strongest protests they could
against the war, uh, going to prison, uh,
by non-violent refusal to cooperate with the draft.
And when I met people like that, I realized,
I thought of the war the way they did it, that it was wrong, that it should end.
And seeing their example was what put into my mind,
what could I now do to help in this war now that I'm ready to go to prison?
Or was that something.
That evolved or did this happen overnight?
That particular perception happened very quickly.
When I saw somebody that I was very impressed by, uh,
announced that he was on his way to prison, which I hadn't foreseen.
I was very a thunder struck by that. Really. In fact,
I went to a men's room at the end of the auditorium,
and I sat down and looked at cried for a long time at what my country had become
that what seemed like the best young men of our country,
that the best thing they could do was to go to prison.
And I thought my country has come to this. It was very, uh,
wrenching and that's, as I say, when I got up from that, wash my face and said,
all right, now,
what can I do if I'm ready now that I'm ready to go to prison as they were.
And it was, uh,
within a few weeks that I started cupping the 7,000 top secret pages of
the Pentagon papers,
the history of the war in hopes that that would help shorten the war.
Do you think this would happen? Do you think you will,
you would be that with lower without having met Patricia you're you're
still, still your wife.
I could say that because Patricia was against the war, uh,
good in a way. So was I, but I was trying to make it less violent LIS uh,
murderous, Reedy than it was. And we broke up over that issue in Vietnam.
I felt she was holding me responsible for the whole aspect of the war.
We came back from my, uh, uh, party were from Negal Sheehan,
who was the reporter, who to whom I later gave the Pentagon paper who, uh,
was leaving Vietnam.
And she had met a diplomat who had been in Hanoi and described the bombing of
civilians, of factories, of, uh, hospitals and bridges and whatnot.
And she said, how to me, how can you be part of this?
And I thought at the time that was unfair. I was trying to stop the bombing,
which I didn't believe in. I was trying to do this and that, I thought,
how can I was engaged at the time? I said,
how can I marry someone who doesn't give me the benefit of the doubt? You know,
and I broke it off essentially for three years.
Of course later I came to realize she was right. I was part of it.
And the Pentagon papers was about, about the war in Vietnam.
It was a lot of information that was kept from the American people about how
that war went.
I intended to give all the documents before on nuclear planning, threats,
nuclear threats plans for the destruction of
hundreds of millions of people, uh,
actually grotesque plans and tended to put them out after the Pentagon papers.
I thought the Pentagon papers deal with the war where the bombs are falling now.
And I should try to do that now toward the others,
with my brother who eventually stored them in a trash dump,
uh, in New York, uh, buried them. And unfortunately,
while I was on trial with the intention, I would put them out. After my trial,
the first trial, I thought there would be a number of trials.
And I would certainly go to prison in the end.
She didn't, she'd be sad because it was a miss miss, miss.
Distributed, all this ground of the trashy.
And my brother was never able to recover the box and then a garbage bag in which
these documents were. So that was, that's what I regretted.
That's a great regret of my life.
So a hurricane took the papers in a way.
Uh, distributed them by the he'd had an iron stove, uh,
marketing the place where he'd buried them.
It was moved about a hundred yards by the hurricane.
He used a bulldozer and various things to try to recover this.
And he got a lot of garbage bags, but none with top secret documents in it.
Because these are papers that probably would have changed history even more.
I would hope that they did the history is, uh,
the most dangerous and tragic kind.
It's been my hope ever since the change that without the documents, eventually,
uh, in this book, I give the substance to the doomsday machine.
I give the substance of that as I could have done then,
but no publisher was willing to do it without the documents.
They didn't think people were interested in nuclear weapons then,
or now this current book of mine was submitted to 17 publishers before
Bloomsbury.
But tell me, I'm just getting curious here, because your brother,
uh, was the one that hit the papers. Uh,
how did he explain what happened to the papers? I mean,
that must've been a difficult one. That phone call must've been a difficult one.
Yeah. He didn't do it on the phone would have been listened to quite a bit,
but he did tell me when he was able to see me.
And he actually did attempt to keep, uh, trying to find them.
And for over a year, he was spending every weekend. Uh, in fact,
at one point he had the help of a friend of his, a woman who was a,
which among other things,
and with a dowsing rod attempted to see if she could find where these things
were that didn't work either. But, uh, in the end I had to conclude that, uh,
they were gone. So that was,
that's probably the greatest regret of my life, uh,
along with not having put out the Pentagon papers.
Yeah. I want to talk about the new care threat,
because it's something that most people, uh,
they don't think about it every day, no, uh.
Or any day people think that the problem went away with the cold war and on
the end of the cold war and say in 1991,
unfortunately the weapons didn't go away and they remain on alert.
They have the same potential for extinguishing most human life on earth
that they did 70 years ago, 60 years ago, 30 years ago,
essentially the threat has remained even though the numbers have gone down,
but the numbers were so grotesquely,
a larger number than was necessary to end life on earth.
That it's still true.
The, the fact that we are after all still here and it's gone well
so far.
Yes, that's right. As the man said,
jumping from the top of the 50th floor and he passes the 28th
floor so far so good. And
I think it's been by an enormous luck.
But, but how, how many people have access to the button? I mean,
how.
Well, you know,
there's a mistaken belief that a nuclear weapon States starting with the U S
only one,
man can authorize the use of those weapons that has never been
true. And how many altogether?
I don't think any president has ever known how far actually it could go.
It's not a small number.
What are you most afraid of that it will start in a small scale,
or that will be.
The, a over Ukraine.
Is there any armed conflict with Russia between Russia and the U S has
a high likelihood of becoming nuclear?
And if that happens with whatever weapons, small tactical weapons,
intermediate range, missiles,
whatever that will escalate to an all-out exchange almost surely.
And what we've known, as I said for 35 years,
is that that doesn't mean killing just billions of people.
It involves killing about 7 billion people because of
effects that I think very few people are yet aware of. Can I,
can I mention what, let me put this in, in to, well, first of all,
what I've just described is that, uh,
in a Swedish journal actually MBO, uh, back in 1982,
and then Carl Sagan and others in 83,
revealed that smoke from burning cities would be lofted by the
explosions,
into the stratosphere where it wouldn't burn out where it wouldn't rain out and
quickly surround the globe blocking 70% of the sunlight,
which would mean ice age conditions on the face of the earth throughout the
globe for over a decade. And more significantly,
even in the cold would kill all the harvests.
And within a matter of months to a year,
nearly everyone would die of starvation.
The numbers who died from famine from that effect will greatly outweigh the
numbers that will die from the immediate effects.
Why we've tolerated this.
I think it goes back to an earlier stage when we didn't know about this,
when I was working for Bundy and president Kennedy, I'd drafted a question,
uh, for the president to give to the joint chiefs of staff.
And the question was, if you're, if our plans are carried out,
which were first strike plans, not starting a war,
but starting a nuclear phase of a war. If there,
as you say was an earlier conflict of some sort over Berlin,
you'll go Slavia Iran, uh, an uprising in the East, East or whatnot.
Our plans were to initiate our major,
all out war plan against the Soviet union and China,
even though China had not been involved, uh,
we were going to destroy the Sino Soviet block, even if it started over Berlin.
So I wanted to know if they understood just how many people
would die. If that happened. It turned out.
They did almost to my surprise within a week or two first week was first
came back in the USSR and China alone.
We would kill 325 million people.
And a week later, they came back with the figures for the rest of the world.
As we death. It turned out that East Europe,
which I hadn't included in the first a hundred million more would die their
attacks on their defenses or their bases. And from fallout,
from radioactive fallout, coating the dust and earth.
That's drawn up by a nuclear explosion with radioactivity that is lethal for a
very wide area, a hundred million in West Europe.
Our allies NATO allies would die from our own weapons without a single
warhead landing there from the radioactive fallout and a hundred million in
the neutral and contiguous areas to the Soviet union,
including all of Scandinavia, Finland, for example,
would be wiped out by the fallout from weapons on the sub patterns,
and then grid with Finland, also radio Sweden,
a neutral country, Norway, a, uh, uh,
NATO member wiped out by our own followed to that,
had these estimates, this amounted to 600 million people,
a hundred Holocaust by our attack.
Add to that the effects of, uh, the Russian response,
which would annihilate Europe, whichever way the wind blew, not from fallout,
but from blast and radiation.
I've always wondered as I worked with NATO and I wrote a speech to NATO for
McNamara, cosmic clearance and so forth,
did the people McNamara was addressing understand that we were talking about
plans that led to their total annihilation.
And yet that's been true from then to now. I've never been clear when,
when they demanded that they be quote defended, uh,
by this or when countries like Sweden.
And so I now understand it from a book by Robert Dellschau hoped that by being
neutral and having no weapons on their territory like Norway or
Denmark, no weapons, they would not be targets in the initial detect.
They didn't seem to understand that that seemed to believe that to be
annihilated in a nuclear war, you had to be targeted. That's not true,
totally not true. There's no neutrality in a thermonuclear war.
They were subject to be annihilated like everybody else,
radioactivity and smoke doesn't pay attention to national borders
or to neutrality or to friend or enemy. It gets everybody.
Um, Danielle, this is, this is, um, uh,
devastating to, to, to hear about that,
that these were actual estimates that they could make,
uh, but not talk about, of course, um,
you became the ultimate whistleblower, um,
of your time. Uh, why do you think there are so few with lovers?
Well, I've asked myself that, uh, for a long time, uh,
it's obvious that I was put on trial facing 12 felony counts, 10 years,
each, uh,
115 year possible sentence that was meant to slow other people down
from following this example. And you would expect that it would,
that there wouldn't be too many people who would decide to do this.
Why almost none.
Actually I waited 39 years until Chelsea Manning revealed as
a comparable amount. I was very happy when that happened. And then it,
the Snowden three years later, I identify with them very much,
but why did it take almost 40 years? W why no others.
But even, even, even if there was a mistrial, uh, and you,
you did not have to go to prison. Did you pay a price anyway?
Well, not what Nixon him had in mind for me, uh, you know,
which was life, life in prison, which I expected, uh, and what I didn't expect.
He also had in mind shutting me up about his threats and sent, uh,
for example,
a dozen people to incapacitate me totally on the steps of the Capitol.
When I was going to rally on May 3rd, 1972, I hadn't expected that,
uh, he listened to me, uh, have the CIA on me and various things,
but none of these worked, uh, he, he had bad luck on this,
which led him to face resignation. And, uh,
I sh I shouldn't say led him to face impeachment and prosecution.
And so he had to resign and it made the war in double,
but a lot of people had to tell proves they weren't expected to tell at that
point, Alex Butterfield had to reveal that the taping,
without which John Dean's revolutions without any proof would not have been
effective, uh, Richardson the special, uh,
had to refuse to fire the special prosecutor,
which an issue that may come up any day or any month now in the current
administration.
But did you lose friends? Did they lose friends?
Uh, I lost all my friends because they all had clearances friends.
Who've known me more than a couple of years.
Very fortunately I had wonderful new friends like Howard Zinn, Noam, Chomsky,
various others that have remained until Howard's death. I was just the gnomes,
a 90th birthday party, uh, about a month ago. And, uh,
so I had wonderful friends,
but no one who'd known me before I was about 40, uh,
the old dropped away because they couldn't afford to be in the same room.
I become radioactive in effect in terms of their own clearances.
So that's why I, uh, I identify so much with Chelsea Manning and Snowden.
They've had the same experience.
Or we, we wrap up here. Um, I have to ask you about,
because I read,
I have to go back to your very early days because you
experienced the tragedy in your very early life. Uh,
and I wonder in what way that shaped you.
Well at the time, you know, earlier on, I would not have said so,
but looking back at my life,
I realized that my father fell asleep at the wheel of a car and crashed into a
culvert, which killed my mother and sister.
I was in the hospital for three and a half months with how old were you?
I was 15 then, and my sister was 14. Uh,
that did reveal to me looking back on it, uh,
that the world could change very suddenly.
I think I'm more open to the knowledge,
the truth that our world could be destroyed very quickly.
It's very hard for other people to even imagine that I think,
and also that it could happen as a result of an authority that I trusted
and loved my father falling, asleep, being inattentive,
and the one had to be vigilant to some extent in a way that I hadn't been,
or couldn't be to keep them awake. I think that did have an effect on me.
Uh, you know, I was,
I'm very honored here to be sitting in the same chair that, uh,
Greta Twinburg occupied or my new hero.
And, uh, I, there's no one on earth that I admire, uh,
more than Greta at this point. And, uh,
I was struck that you asked her a similar question about her Asperger's, uh,
disease autism. And if she's right in what she told you,
that her background and her character Asperger's had contributed
to her perspective and her courage and whatnot,
then we need a lot more Asperger's in the world. I would say
[inaudible] is a walking advertisement for Asperger's or autism,
and really our survival.
Yeah. The similarities between what you.
In my own, each of us may have had in our own background,
Chelsea Manning had a very strange and tortured background in many ways,
which I'm sure revealed her to the fact that people can be
mistaken. And they're very broad. The scale can be asleep in what they're doing.
It's what I have the same is I was listening to her. I loved that program, uh,
which I watched at midnight, listening. Your assistant sent me links,
and I've never been so impressed that I was so excited that I, in my mind,
I reverted back to my old Marine Corps language.
And I wrote to him in credible.
[Inaudible]. I was never, I was never in my reading, Danielle,
but I will say it still say to meet you while I was in credible.
[inaudible]. Thank you so much for being here. Thank you. I
hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations.
Please hit subscribe.